freedom of speech is great right  but without money freedom of money you  don't have freedom of speech so i can  stand from my rooftop and scream  lockdowns don't work the injections  could be dangerous you know but that's  not gonna do anything if i cannot use my  money to get somewhere where i can be  heard if i can't get to where the  protest is then i can't add any value to  the protests and eventually take down  this communist system that we that we  have growing it's authoritarian reality  that we're starting to live in and so  without money you don't have freedom of  speech so we need to have freedom to  spend our money the leian show